okay four people joining this livestream
this is a design meeting about wolf
language and it's actually a
doubleheader meeting we will be talking
about tools for analyzing code and then
the top of the hour we will switch to
talking about code robusta fication and
error handling so we are watching
Brunton screen here and we're about to
start hearing about the first item here
profiling often language code so I don't
know quite what this is about so let's
take a look yeah a lot of this is going
to be showing simply showing this
functionality so it is possible to
instrument Wolfram language code and I
thought that the first two really good
examples of doing that would be
profiling code that you run and getting
coverage reporting of code terrific
let's see the examples and we have you
know plenty of other options but you
know I want to the main - yes so I have
reports but I can show you what the
transcript kind of looks like with no I
want to see the whole process I mean I
want to see how do you do how do you do
the instrumentation what do you actually
do yeah so you know there's a there's a
packet that you load and you so the
first thing to be aware of that I would
like to change in the future is that
this operates directly on source code
itself and it's not you know it it's not
in down values or anything like that and
so you know maybe that's a limitation
right off from the start on hold on hold
on hold on we got a raw source file yeah
and what we're gonna get is we're going
to run that source file and then we're
gonna get profiling information is that
correct you will after you've
instrumented the car no no no no no I'm
trying to understand the workflow even
the source file gets rewritten and it's
files err it's all of the Wolfram
language code folder rewritten to add
instrumenting data and then
it gets executed and Instrumentation
okay so there's a very heavy weight
thing there's nothing you just go into
your notebook and you annotate something
in the notebook you do something this is
something where so this is it by the way
though I mean does it use does it kind
of like I don't know how to put it like
like textually instrumented or does it
use I can activate it and stuff like
that does it go I think is what you mean
yeah so you can see so for example this
is the original source of like a package
and this would be the instrumented
source of the package and the only
difference it this is all full form but
the difference is that there are rappers
that are now inserted around the code
that insert the file name and line and
you know in function name information
for all of the functions that you're
running so that you you know you can
keep track of that information so it's
basically it's the same file it's this
it's just as wrappers you know around
all of the right-hand sides of all of
these function bodies because even
though line 12 in line 15 have the same
function name you know you want to mark
them up differently and so you know
these have different wrappers you know
line 29 similarly yeah I got it so the
point is that this is going to alright
okay I get I get this okay so go back
okay so the concept of the workflow here
is you've got a bunch of source files
you're going to rewrite the source files
then you're gonna run the source files
and generate some kind of report from
them is that the idea
yeah yep and and right now none of this
is doable at the level of granular
notebook type stuff it's all just
heavyweight no source file profiling but
let's see what it generates okay yeah so
you know and you load and you make sure
it's the right but I understand so so
here you know I mean we have no idea how
you love because presumably it has a
differently named file which is the
profile rewritten version of that file
right it was started off as a dot WL
file and then there is a dot wlp file or
something
is the profile version of the file there
in different directories yeah wait a
minute wait a minute why well because
you need to manage so you know if we
look at the yeah I saw what you did I
told you to go back to that file you
need to be able to coverage or you know
I catch it I get it okay you go back to
the previous file the notebook okay come
actually your notebook okay so what you
did there was you said there was a
source and destination for the profile
instrument yeah right okay
these are all I know that okay so now
profile evaluate down there runs the
thing in the profile system okay now how
do you get out I see so that is the
analog of timing of something yeah guts
out the profile rotor okay
and it's heavyweight still enough that
there is post processing that's needed
so you do that with the data and then
you can get the report you know that
comes out so so hold on hold on hold on
okay okay can you run all this please
just run this file no yeah not at the
beginning I want to see how long it
takes yeah yeah so that's that's
instructive and I've just I mean this
really is starting from scratch well
okay so yeah this is C so how big is the
file how big of these clothes well this
is the entire compile repo so I mean
there there are hundreds maybe even
thousands of dot M files here okay
you're not using the standardized
progress monitoring system correct
correct
why not I just I haven't revisited this
this yeah but I mean all all of
instrumentation is due for kind of I
wrote this a while ago yeah yeah okay
all right fine okay about this long
oh yeah fine so it's a big it's a big
set of directories and takes a while to
do it okay still though if you're
talking hundreds of files that's that's
not bad not terrible yeah you know and
I've actually profiled itself you know
to find the bottlenecks and everything
so okay you can ignore that message for
the moment because okay okay okay okay
just sufficient to just tell us to
ignore the message yeah so function
compile of just that reno so now you
have some profile data and then you get
a report back about how long everything
took and so yeah the top ones kind of a
long directory name there but so what
you can see probably carries that's a
data set Chris Carlson has made this
into a data set but I and I have not
brought in those changes into it so fun
too but there there is something
floating around yeah okay so it should
be a data set yeah okay I mean so yeah
so you can see you know oh you know
create instruction I get it I get it I
get it I could see what it's saying okay
so wait a second so then it's sorted
like that okay yeah
because it does dataset have a sorting
interface and it's typesetting I don't
remember yes yeah because sorting I mean
interactive sorting for a report like
this will be really critical I think yes
I thought I thought that data set I
thought it just has minimization things
unless this is brand new its new okay
this is sorta general data are just
didn't it like goodbye the variable and
I sort it in the interactive interface
does it sort this symbol no that's just
purely purely visual um I really like to
see the data type version of this but
but I mean this looks highly useful okay
I don't think I'll show the pie chart in
a second but everyone take note so you
know you have anonymous functions here
you know here and here and here and
further down so just remember that
everything is computable you can get a
bunch of data out and do whatever you
want with it
and so I just made a pie chart of you
know the self time percentages and you
see the second one is actually function
but we're talking about different
functions all being added up here so you
know that's kind of all of those should
be counted differently so naively you're
going to you know they all have the same
name so they're all counted together but
you don't actually want that with
anonymous functions so obviously so you
know just that kind of thing to be aware
of and I say function is just it's just
a special exception that it gets
functions get counted by their contents
as opposed to by just function yeah I
mean it would just be their line number
well I mean even I guess even that's not
sufficient you know line number in
column but and there might be other
other function like things that would
have the same name that you want to come
on any curried function it's gonna have
this polite because its head is not what
you think it is yeah yeah sure so it's
just stuff to be aware of yeah I
function it's more extreme though
because if it uses like select or
something it's you know it's reasonable
say oh yes selector spending this time
right it's just function because
functions just means nothing right if
you tell oh it's spent all of its time
and function it tells me nothing right
instances of functions they all occur in
different locations so they should could
be separated by their instances I think
that's what we saw in the last report
that they were separate it's just in the
pie chart that their combined yeah
I mean that I you know I don't know what
data were being given to separate them I
mean it seems like you know I don't know
it might be interesting to assign some
sort of IDs to them or have some other
Providence information that can be
tracked in some way maybe there is and
maybe it just wasn't simple to put it in
the pie chart I don't know my number and
column would be enough to you know okay
yeah I mean arguably you want to just
have the whole function body but but you
know you wouldn't want to display it no
I don't know just and just ionize it in
the data set yeah I mean you could just
literally icon eyes the function body
you could say [ __ ] for short nice
another short I can I seems it all
strange but well the point about ionizes
well it depends on how you're doing it
um this is a detail though okay let's
let's zoom out for a minute okay so this
is a very heavyweight profiling system
which is you know people want things for
much more lightweight purposes um in
addition well in addition but maybe it's
the same thing maybe it can be made to
be the same thing okay can you go back
to scroll back up the other thing is
though is I think that for a lightweight
thing like look this is doing it
lexically which which maybe has a
performance improvement for these big
things but I think for like if I just
have a piece of code and I want to
profile it which you can already do
using their like runtime with the
debugger and stuff like that in
principle which nobody else I
occasionally do but but it is also kind
of we had some weird properties but but
the point is that I think for for that
what you want is you want you know you
don't want to do anything Lex it you
just want to do in activate
and stuff like that inactivates style
analysis that's how you would do it in a
more lightweight way but I'm not trying
not anyway electrically I mean I don't
understand what why not
behind the scenes do it lexically let us
take the notebook contents and do this
in other words well but you might want
to the points for smaller things right
there two cases the case of I have a big
project like the compiler project might
want to profile it that's that's this
case the other case is like I have this
one particular line of code and I want
to profile it well I have a small
function that's three lines long sure
right and this is the case that the
current debugger profilers set up for
and in that case I think it's a little
crazy to do you know to be like okay
I've made a new line I've copied down
your line to it a new line that has a
bunch of weird names in it and you're
gonna run this and it's gonna produce a
report I think that seems strange it's
correct for the big case had to say
something so you know if if we had a
mode where we could use Brenton's parser
to load you know Wolfram language code
then we wouldn't need to do this copy
file it's just purely because the kernel
parser is is to ossified and inflexible
to add this this sort of information and
the metering the you know the workbench
profiler is using the debugger metering
thing which which has a different
philosophy I think I think what Brenton
is doing is actually better it's more
precise and it's more similar to how
other other languages work so I mean
this step of you know the profile
instrument I mean that really could that
really could go away I mean you know you
could just have what you're saying is
that and so certainly for the big cakes
right certainly for the project white
case that's that's for sure but the
question is is this is this also the
same architecture you want for a single
line the debugger the workbench you have
the posit has to be in a debug mode in
order to further the profiling to work
and the same thing could happen here if
it's in you know debug mode it could use
Brenton's parser for example and so
let's look at how that would actually
work
so you're saying instead of shift-enter
you would have some different thing what
you would do is you it bogging I'm sorry
writer debug you know there's a menu
item in the front-end I know but but it
doesn't it is not something people find
usable sure yeah so let's talk about how
we make it usable so one possibility
would be that essentially we annotate
cells with this cell is being parsed in
a way or has been parsed in a way that
has this background information so I'm
saying so let's imagine that we had a a
you know command option shift return
thing that is a special way of
evaluating a cell okay which would tag
that cell as presumably having I don't
know whether it would actually have sad
stuff rewritten in it or whether it
would simply have a thing that says I'm
I'm supposed to be sent to the Brenton
Pazza whether than the standard Colonel
parser this is a bit confused when
you're going from the front end it's
it's sending more information over in
the boxes the front end does that grant
loading stuff from package files so it
is nothing to do with shift-enter that's
just you know how the evaluations
getting launched you see that they're
different different things were just
that Brendon's thing runs on strings as
opposed to boxes correct
Brett correct yes on files yes it's the
Alec files yes like the workbench
profiler does yes okay so fun but but so
what I'm saying is what he's doing is
he's taking a file he's rewriting it to
put instrumentation in it okay what I'm
saying is in the front end you got to be
able to do the same thing that is to say
this cell I'm going to set to be one
that has instrumentation in it right so
you could do that that is like having
the debug menu item at the cell level
yeah but Brenton can you just bring down
the
you click on the evaluation yep so it's
like having that setting debugger at the
cell level let me sit let me see what
happens if I do this well if you do that
then you have to now go and reevaluate
code so that's not the right thing that
was a that was a bad UX decision it's
it's the same as it's the same as the
the the cell level doesn't know the
point is once you're in debugger mode
when you run things it'll run and I'll
say parenthesis debug right so the point
is you just want to do that at the cell
level and then I'm suggesting I'm
suggesting that you tag the cell and you
know you convert it just like you can
converts a traditional form or something
you invert to a form where this just
changes its that the default is you know
it just changes it so that every time
you run a cell it'll now be in debug
mode exactly right but you don't have a
visual indication that it has been
debugged right you do you do actually so
if you press debugger actually and enjoy
this won't you stop showing the monetary
structure I mean another possibility is
that we should always send this debug
info no I mean I have to imagine there's
some performance serious performance
issue and it's completely irrelevant to
most people well the Mormont's issue one
of the goals with my new parser is to
completely overcome whatever performance
issue there would be with providing this
information from from dot WL files you
know just from just better engineering
of you know of the parser I believe that
it should always be on this information
should always be on I'm sorry you're
completely losing me here what are you
talking about so like I packaged gets
loaded in the kernel right now unless
it's in debug mode you know there's no
information about I know there's no
instrumentation I'm well aware of that
so you're suggesting that hold on hold
on you're suggesting that in the data
structure
that is kept we're in the that the the
annotation information the lexical
annotation information be preserved in
the kernel is that what you're
suggesting one
for example in the down value structure
somehow he'll be specific
be specific where does the evaluator the
evaluator is not going to have to dig
through lexical annotation information
to evaluate something correct something
off on the side no like there won't be
any performance hit the performance hit
I will it be achieved by hashing a
welding time no wait a minute will it be
achieved by hashing or what
how will it know what the what the
corresponding you could do it with
hashing for example you could say take
this piece of code maybe you could do it
that way
where do you keep the tag that is the
information about what the lexical the
expert pointer itself could just be is
just the tag that's how the debug parser
it uses the expert address but that's
perfectly reasonable no no there are
negatives with that because when you
start sharing experts like symbols are
shared or on the empty list then then
the disaster oh it's it falls to pieces
yes so I think Brenton's method is is
kind of better
what is Benton's method well he's he's
adding annotations into the code which
which can get stripped out no no no no
no no no no that's not going to work
because then the evaluator has to dig
through the annotations that's not going
to work hold on hold on we couldn't have
a processing step where in normal cases
that gets thrown away once or it gets
stored in some and seems like a very bad
idea this seems like building a very
giant structure for a very special case
not a good idea okay so let's let's
retrenched to try and think about a
better idea okay because that's not
going to work I mean I think it's doable
right if you care about profiling a
whole package this system is basically
correct right and just you know point to
your folder semantics have it annotate
whatever and if you're profiling and if
you're profiling a single line then I
think an interface that is closer to the
debugger one although probably I mean
like look the question is why don't you
just have a top level function that's
called profile or something like that
that basically does this and it uses
probably it does it probably doesn't do
it lexically probably uses
activate and stuff like that and it you
know and it will probably have a
performance hit that doesn't matter
because it's just when you're profiling
it that it actually yes I agree these
changes right right so I mean so what we
would look at there would be we just
find a random piece of code here to use
the song hold on one second
Amy it seems like maybe like okay I
don't know the details of how the
debugger profiler works but maybe you
know it's doing some no magic low-level
stuff you know in the evaluator to make
it so that it doesn't make a significant
performance head but it seems like that
doesn't sorry exactly it's doing magic
level stuff we evaluate I don't like it
right okay the point is I think that in
modern times you know you can just do
this just just use in activate or
something like that and run the pieces
separately and don't worry about the
performance hit it just doesn't matter
that much I think what's that sorry I
what you just using activate means okay
what it means is you type this you type
profile and then you say profile
evaluate for example of Turing machine
whatever it is causal graph and then
what it presumably does is it takes what
would it actually do it has to go
through and find the definitions that
are going to be used here it would use
the same kind of definition finder that
we use for cloud deploy and so on and
basically find the definitions create a
shadow version of these of this these
definitions that is like Brenton's
separate you know separate directory
create a shadow version in which
everything has been inactivated and
tagged and then run it see what I'm
saying so in other words it's doing or
it could even do if it wants it to it
could even do exactly use Brenton's code
and that might be a good idea where
essentially what it's doing is the exact
same thing that it would do if I were to
say cloud deploy of this thing it would
take go go down and find the the
dependency chains get the code write the
code out somewhere annotate it with
Brenton's stuff run it and bring back
the profile results now the only the
only difference would be that instead of
having explicit
business doesn't really have line
numbers it would have to when it picks
up the code it would somehow have to
have cell ID information that makes
sense to people
oh I sell ID I mean why is it not just
by definition like like why does it even
need to okay in this case I don't even
think it necessarily needs to tell you
you know where in your notebook it came
from I can just tell you this is
function name it's you know III think
this kind of the watershed line here is
you're either in a mode where you are
trying to track things back to some
concrete syntax representation or you're
in a mode we don't care about concrete
syntax at all yeah well fine
profile evaluate in the first
approximation we could exactly use
Brenton's code basically we just write
out write this out into a temporary file
run Brenton's code do the evaluation
bring back his profile report just all
packaged in a way that's easy for people
to use for small granular cases yeah
yeah yeah I mean the only minor
complaint you know this is not a real
complaint is that you know this sort of
lexical turn it into a string approach
you know though it's the correct thing
for packages is a bit ugly for small
consists of codes because it's just I
can go and read it but well I agree but
at least we could get this up and
running and see what it feels like yeah
I mean right Brenton you understood the
idea yeah I mean there are if the code
is already loaded it could create
confusion and the kernel too I mean
there are issues like if there con to it
because I've got a different idea okay
guys guys guys guys guys we're not
running in a separate kernel why not run
profile evaluation a separate kernel
yeah we should think about that Brendan
you know you can swap down values in and
out yeah yeah yeah I mean no don't do it
that way I don't think that's a good way
to do it I think I think that's worse
than having something probably I mean
know why I'm not sure I just think it's
cleaner to do this to have a be a
throwaway kernel that does it but okay
so now if we were doing this we have
various people on our live stream saying
that they in we got one person was 16
years in usage and 7 or 8 years of usage
nobody has understood the debugger so
possibly possibly Tom and Christopher
are the only people on this some
front-end debugger or the work -
debugger well I don't know I think they
think people are referring to the
front-end debugger right ok ok look
that's the thing about the debugger is
that it's like there are various things
and even stuff like highlighting a hat
you know the head that produced a
message and stuff like that there are
things like that that it does that are
actually very useful but it's just that
nobody ever does it because it's kind of
arcane well and because of this tagging
this need to do tagging that people find
obscure and not easy to understand yeah
yeah and I mean I think it would help a
lot if I mean the best thing would be if
it didn't if it could do the tagging
itself automatically and then remove the
tag you know it could it could tag and
for example if you want to run the thing
as [ __ ] you know it could tag and
indicate in the cell bracket that has
done the tagging if you say oh I want to
run this as fast as possible I don't
want to let tagging you just go click it
somehow and it D tags itself or it gives
you the version but doesn't have tagging
so why do you even what is the advantage
to sort of statically tagging like ok
cuz cuz right in the in the Breton case
right the case of the big packages then
of course it makes sense because you
just want to insert the tags to be able
to run it and profile it and change etc
but in the case of a single line of code
or a few lines of code in a notebook III
the thing I don't understand is why you
can't just when you run it it will add
the it'll add the annotations and add
the tags it will evaluate it it'll
collect the information from the tags
and then it'll produce the results I
don't understand why you need to have
tagging as a separate like user level
step Tom because it just won't be it
just won't take a long time
I I mean I mean the youth it has to be
connected
I mean rightly or wrongly workbench
partha ties the code two lines of source
code because you want to see your source
but you know when you hit a breakpoint
you want to see what code you actually
running you see so you could understand
it and maybe fix it you know what I
think we need to do it the next segment
of this meeting is going to be about the
confirm and close mechanism and maybe
what we need to think about there is
something in the confirm mechanism that
allows you to have a breakpoint
breakpoints or another thing would be
like line numbers and stuff I mean I
think this comes back to it what John
said earlier which is basically there
are two cases the case that I'm working
on a package I care about where my
errors are occurring you know in the
plain text of my code and so on because
I have a lot of it and then there's the
case of I'm in a notebook and I have
like two lines of code I'm trying to
profile I just don't care and to be
clear I wasn't making the distinction
between notebooks and text files I was
making the distinction between I have a
representation whether it's in a
notebook or a text file where I want the
system to be right to care about the
pointer point me to the specific
character offset line number box
whatever as opposed to I just don't even
you know just act like you know the code
got in there from the ether and just
give me a report you know based on
definitions how do I switch off a bug
and now I'm totally afraid because you
know what do i do I just check that off
yeah now nothing bad will happen correct
you run the session I have to restart
the session in fact all the definitions
are already there you don't you don't
have to reven rerun anything okay okay
um all right so look I think you know
heading for a profile evaluate that
works using this rather hacky mechanism
that I suggested that can just directly
leverage Brenton's existing code seems
like a useful experiment to try and and
then with respect to observe rentin you
can go that's why don't you share again
okay so then what we're looking at here
is you're saying um you're going to run
this so so I don't really understand why
so profile evaluate for you here
does not pre run the profiling you're
doing a separate step that that pre runs
the you know it will be basically create
profile create profile herbal version is
that first thing there right the finger
up at the top it's create it's correct
yes right so profile instrument is
create a profile herbal version there
yeah right and what similar thing do we
have that takes a directory and returns
a directory I'm not sure are you trying
to find analogies with yes I'm trying to
find analogy so we know what to name
this thing it's basically gonna take I
mean it's something like one of the
packet build system things well you take
a directory and do something with it
why don't we just like you know do do
get all needs in in a profiling
environment and have this happen
seamlessly yeah like I want to stress
that I like this is kind of just a hack
I mean okay so you want to keep that
women you don't want to keep a copy of
the profile annotated source
you don't care had to do it on the fly
it was took a long time here that I
wouldn't on the grounds that you need to
do it on the fly because you will have
changed your code or something or what
yeah I mean the implication is that you
are also modifying this based on you
know reports and you have this loop this
development loop going okay but I mean a
better thing to do would be to use some
kind of hashing to determine for all the
files there did any of them actually
change don't bother to rebuild the
profilers cursor is it writing it out it
might be writing it out it's processing
big chunks of code well the colonel
low exhort of his
pretty pretty quick okay no no it's not
his code it's it's going through and
annotating all the code okay let's
assume that yeah I think I think Tom's
question is a fair one it's not a
hundred percent obvious to me what
consumes the time I need to profile the
profiler yeah sure
I mean if you can just you know just
just do always do it if it's cheap cheap
ish yeah I don't think that's going to
work but look the bottom line is you
want to be able to say profile evaluate
anywhere and have that just work so in
other words in other words you could
basically say when you say get when you
do the get on to load in the definitions
from from those files have it be the
case that you can do get you know a
profile version of get that will
automatically store all the profiling
material however that's done whether
it's a separate file or it's done on the
fly you know who knows maybe if the
profile get or profile needs or
something like that yeah oh okay all
right let's move on to the next segment
of the meeting okay I think we've we've
got the you know understand so data says
what we need to see for the output of
this and you know the tools of what what
are the you know what are the ways to
make higher level things I would suggest
function repository functions that
operate on that data set that do a
variety of things that people might find
useful in terms of making histograms
picking top functions making pie charts
and then we'll make a collection of
those things and maybe they will become
more mainstream later okay coverage
tests right so code coverage very
similar to profiling not I go can use
the same can it use this the same
annotation information or not they call
different functions if things were
abstracted maybe it could use the same
information yeah yeah what's up with it
but but so you have to make a decision
I'm gonna profiler I'm gonna do coverage
is that correct correct right now yeah
that seems wrong but I mean if unless it
has some desperate reason for having to
work that way well it's different
information so we profiling yeah yeah
yeah I mean so okay so let's see the
coverage report fair so for people that
are not familiar this is a very standard
ELCA coverage report generation that's
tied into this so that we can see this
so the result for us we should be able
to make a graph that is we should a
graph as in a thing with flows in the
graph I mean this is something where it
is trying to make the thing as a sort of
spreadsheet right but for us a function
calls a function calls a function we're
basically getting path weights done a
graph right yeah that's another way of
visualizing yeah right and that will be
very very useful I'm much less confusing
in many ways than something like this in
something with graphs you can basically
treat as like a heat map of you know how
many times a function is called and
different colors and it's all very nice
too yeah so you know it's a little
complicated because if F calls G and F
calls and H calls G there's a question
of you know there different ways that
you might present that graph um
yeah or or rig recursion as well yes
recursion is another case but still I
think it's a it's a thing we can do that
is beyond the kind of spreadsheet like
form but why don't you show show what
you can do right now yeah so I mean this
is just the result and so you click
through to the file numeric I don't know
why I just clicked on that it's doing it
so in it you are generating a dot L
cough file or something is that right
yep yep I see which is then exported to
some other tool yeah so you can run the
elk of command and Jen HTML and do all
of this and I think it would be nice to
even just have this even representation
in a notebook also but it's nice it's
nice to interoperate with these kinds of
tools so who are writing out the raw
data for L pub so for example in the
import system we could have something
which reads an alcove
and generates whatever stuff it should
generate from it yep which we could we
already support like import/export for
alcove no I'm never heard of that I
don't believe we don't know yeah okay so
that would seem very useful to begin
with right so then then an import
element could be make the graph make the
spreadsheet etc yep okay fine so so
let's so you would say coverage
evaluator go back go back to your other
screen what somebody's asking what
coverage means it means whether lines of
code have been executed when you run a
function um you should run the tests
wait in that I've done it before I
definitely don't want to do that
interactively but yes and and and and
just to add what Stephen said for people
listening under the theory that lines of
code that you've never executed are more
likely to have bugs in them because
you've never seen what the code actually
did and run your tests wait so that you
know that you're reaching all your code
in tests you know and so how does this
work with the verification test
no it's our testing framework in that
you would run no I know but one would
like to be able to get to be able to in
that testing report have something which
gives coverage yeah that would be
inverted from how what's really possible
but yeah yeah yes that that would be
that would make sense yep okay so what
decisions do we need to make here I mean
this is this looks like there's a
question of how we make you know this
just in time creation of profiling and
coverage tagging information which i
think is necessary so that you know
coverage evaluation profile evaluate can
just work
well don't wait it's more complicated
because you need to know what the source
code is you see in coverage evaluate
you're just doing an evaluation but you
don't know where what don't know we just
went through that Tom we've got two
cases we've got the case where you have
a bunch of files where the thing has to
be pre tagged with some kind of special
version of get when it's read in case
number one case number two which we have
not properly addressed is what to do
with cell IDs in a notebook okay
case number three is pure disembodied
code okay well we expect to either yeah
yeah but coverage is more is trickier
for pure disembodied curb because you
have to define the universe of the code
function you could do by head yeah it
was in the code that's what I would do
it becomes a little bit it does become a
bit lexical though because of course you
know if I'm calling some system function
I don't care what fraction of the
coverage of that system function I'm
getting right well it's only it's only
relevant to the down values of user code
yeah yeah exactly right that's what it
should do it should it should report
coverage by I mean in a perfect world it
would report coverage by down value of
so if F has seven different down values
you know f of one is separate from F of
zero in separate from f of X blank etc
it's got to be able to report coverage
for each of those down values that's
feasible fine okay
all right let's let's take the very end
of your meeting and then we're going to
switch over to the different topic yeah
so that that was a code instrumentation
where things are at and really I just
wanted to show you what's on github
right now yeah so we so for code tools
code parser and code inspector are repos
that are up on github right now I'm
pleased to see that they're very popular
starred repos you know a lot of
like it so far good and what do they do
what do these do this is nasty
okay yeah so what nice thing is that
I've hooked up with the parser is github
actions where when we push up any
changes to code to github it actually
goes about downloading wolfram engine
installing it activating it building the
code that I just pushed up installing
the code and then running all the tests
you know to verify that everything was
fine so this is an automatic thing for
example that can just run by virtue of
you know github API you know github
actions that they've allowed people to
extend and plug into so this is just a
thing that just kind of works on github
and you know we can just use it and see
the results whenever you know any
changes are pushed up and anyone can do
this and so if I have a piece of often
language code and I'm storing it on
github and I want to
do what you want to run verification
tests on it okay oh you might have C
code you want to build some test suite
of some kind already okay this is really
cool I mean this is this is a standard
thing that you have on github is you
know these actions and you can have an
action that's like you know run the
tests and then it report back coverage
yeah and it's like what and as a for for
example and the way in which it's used
if somebody submits you know contributes
a pull request you want to be able to
run all of the standardized tests on
that pull request before you spend a lot
of time reviewing it yeah so whose
computer is this running on um as your
cloud thing and Microsoft fine fine fine
okay it's running from um who's paying
for it like this how does that work you
can upload an artifact to github that
has your report plus the boat yeah
that's true yep that's a good point um
this is all free but I mean it's github
like github is saying like oh you give a
job to github and github will run it and
the job you've given is to install
Mathematica and run all this stuff and
basically github is running it for free
um no one's complained about any
bandwidth or anything yet okay I mean
there's a completely separate discussion
going on which isn't appropriate for
this meeting but but which you should
plug in to brenton okay make sure I mean
John you can perhaps connect brenton to
the other discussion with github yeah
okay um okay that's cool I mean I'm not
sure I fully understand this but so what
is this this is like a a make file or a
Jenkins job or whatever or puppet
whatever these things are called I mean
it's a it's it's a it's a thing which is
running what specifies what's the source
of the actions that are being specified
here
this ya know squirrel can't find a
special location
yeah okay so it's a llamo script that
runs against that is running essentially
on the github infrastructure as to do
these actions okay it's cool um very
nice it's very nice and so I know it's
and and so the key thing at the I mean
most of it is just kind of setup to get
you know will for mention up and running
but the key thing would be right at the
bottom which is now you know we have
some actual tests here that we want to
run and we want to ensure that those
tests ran successfully and all that this
is just running the actual this is an
actual wls file so nice very nice okay
so um next time
brenton we need to seal the code
formatting stuff and and also need to
talk more about the integration of code
assistance with the front end and with
the cloud I'm not sure we've live
streaming any of those things people
would I can't find that pretty
interesting so hopefully we'll we'll
live stream next discussion about that
alright I think it's time to switch to a
different topic so Christopher are you
gonna share or did you say nothing to
share I should probably share because
you'd have to install packet right now I
don't think it's in a place where you
can use it all right okay great so okay
let's just go a basic intro to what this
is all about because we've had a bunch
of other people join yes so this this is
about what I'm calling code robusta
fication but it's about mechanisms for
handling errors and exceptions in code
okay yes with with the main focus right
now being on like you know larger pieces
of code but but yeah so so okay so we
had a previous meeting about this also
summarize the basic design right now so
the basic setup is that there there
Quotes two functions there's basically a
function colored clothes and a function
call to confirm although there are many
different types of confirm and the basic
idea is that encloses a bit like catch
and confirm is a bit like throw and so
you put in close around sort of the you
know a big block of code and then you
put confirms in the middle of it and the
confirms are kind of like asserts that
will assert that you know nothing is
failed and nothing is missing and stuff
like that in places where there
shouldn't be failed and missing things
and then if a confirm is sort of
triggered then it will it will throw a
failure up to the enclose which can then
handle the failure and return something
so you know a very basic example right
so I've got some nice names by the way
what's nicer than last time
yeah I mean if you have if you have
other name suggestions there we can I
mean easier I think are the better names
I can't remember what the last names
were but these they're okay I think I
remember one of them was guard yeah I
think was contain and guard this is
better it's okay so they're kind of two
main things I think we should talk about
which is types of confirms and some of
the detailed behavior of enclose
so so first just to give a bit you know
basic example right so basically if the
basic confirm just checks for failure Q
and missing Q right now it might also
check for messages but that's what it is
right now and if it get if it doesn't
trigger if the confirm doesn't trigger
it just lets this stuff blow through it
like echo or something like that and
then if it does trigger it we'll throw a
failure object up to be enclosed which
can optionally handle it and return
something or I can just return the
failure object by default so that's the
basic behavior so let me see
so the first maybe the first thing we
should talk about is like the the
details of how and close works because
there's some there's some complicated
semantics that came out of last meeting
so so so one of the one of the features
of enclose right now is that if you give
it a tag it will be quotes dynamic like
throw and catch but if you don't give it
a tag it will be lexical it's like oh
you know for example right here if I
define function here
and I run this it will fail ignore this
but but it will fail because the
confirmed doesn't see being closed
around it because it was not lexically
inside of it but if you give it a tag
and then run it then that has no problem
and it use it works like thrown cash so
good if your argument fast for people
okay okay it's a do people understand
this issue this is a very tricky issue I
understand the issue I I mean I'm a
little bit concerned about the fact that
you know this feels a little bit like I
mean I suppose the fact that it's
strictly lexical is perhaps a saving
grace right but the fact that there was
no throw that no catch that could catch
all throws you know has long been an
issue well actually this is another
thing that we're talking about and that
I was sort of proposing as a change to
throw which is that I think throw should
get a third argument analogous to the
third argument of like time constrained
which is like evaluated and returned if
there is no catch
right so time constraint has a fail
exper which is evaluated and and you
know if well there's no such thing as a
catch for time constrained but you get
what I'm saying so so right now throw
only as two arguments but you could just
give it a third argument which is the
fail expert right on live stream is is
some is asking about how this differs
from check and throw and catch and so on
the whole point is to make streamlined
code that doesn't have to change its
control flow to deal with throw and
catch right so so I mean the usual thing
you do with thrown catch is if I want to
you know run some some piece of code and
I want to check if it worked I use a
module or something I save the piece of
you know the output of that code in a
variable and I say if missing Q of X
then throw etc and so you have to you
know you have to sort of change the
whole structure of your codes the goal
is to you know let you do this without
changing the structure of your code
right and the point is not the same
assert because confirm if if it confirms
correctly it just evaluates to whatever
that value was confirm only complaint
only does something if the confirmation
fails confirm I mean and click confirm
and throw are kind of like echo and
print you know it's analogous thanks
confirm breaks out of the control flow
that you're in that's correct if the
could we ever nation fails then it
breaks the control flow right so you
don't even visit those other parts with
with bad data but but I was wondering
this there's a question of Rick let's
Annette sort of triggering and failing
gracefully is there a sort of recovery
doesn't close have recovery can you do
it yes yeah they're two pieces of
recovery so the first thing is that
confirm all the confirms have kind of a
they have they have different arguments
structures but they all have a second
argument you know which right now is
just called info but basically you know
if I if I put something here I can say
you know what type of failure it was so
I can say you know you know it was
failed right and and then in the failure
object that gets thrown that information
is communicated so basically you can
communicate which confirm did this error
come from and then encloses second
argument is a function that gets applied
to the failure object what's applied to
the failure object if a failure is
thrown right so so this can be the
handler function so for example here I
could just you know this would be a
simple thing to do right where it just
you know returns this this field and so
on right so it's animal this is the
handling function and this is how you
communicate extra information about
where the failure was I'm not sure we
necessarily want to get derailed by this
but this proposed third argument for
throw I guess at what point are you
thinking it will like if we like
basically the
out well if you if you get all the way
to the main loop and you still have an
active throw then you replace it with
this third argument I think so yeah i
mean i think it's it's right there's
this i mean like this function i think
called catch everything how this is
implemented and right now it throws a
message and I think alternatively it can
it can you know if there was a message
and returns the held throw so I think if
it sees a three argument throw then it
could just return the value and return
the third argument the only the only
light could be a function applied then
you could use the same one in many
places it could be a function that gets
applied to the payload of confirmed
weight the thrower we're talking about
the throws right so one question is
right you could make it an F and then it
gets you you run basically f of value
here right that's what I'm saying
I mean the only thing about that is you
kind of know what the value is because
you called the throw yeah but you you
know that means every confirm you have
to rewrite with a special I'm we're not
talking about confirm we're talking
about throw Tom you were talking about
an argument to throw to throw okay what
whatever you you still you if it's a
function you can use the same function
in many places in many threads let's not
get derailed with this let's go back to
confirm because I think there's a couple
of fairly important points that have not
been been I mean we should talk about
the different kinds of confirm but also
the really important point is how to
confirm and enclose or a pair and a
given a confirm has to find its it's
appropriately matching in close and the
question is how does it do that because
the fact that the second argument
changes it from lexical to dynamic is
weird
I think yeah it is weird it I think it
should be one or the other clever well
here's the problem I mean the problem is
right so first of all
in there's a problem I think with
throw-and-catch if you use them in the
default way which we discussed last time
which is that basically you need to use
a tag if you're doing anything serious
because otherwise you know you can catch
user throws yeah like that and so you
know at some level so the lexical the
advantage of the lexical version is that
it avoids using tags and it's still sort
of safe right and I think that basically
90% of cases should be done with the
lexical version and that basically for
problems like oh I have this you know
I've I've a function which calls another
function and the inner function might
return a failure then I think you just
want to have two layers of enclose and
if you're just using confirm and stuff
like that it's easy to propagate those
errors up you know and so you can you
can sort of do it all lexically but then
you know and so I think that that would
be 90% of cases and then the only reason
for supporting the dynamic the tag
version would just be because there
probably a few cases like with nested
encloses where you said really need to
be able to specify that I think it's the
same thing as with module and block most
of the time you can use module but
occasionally you need to use block um
but let's write that does
two different functions so why not I
have a confirm in a lexical confirm or a
confirm and dynamic confirm if you think
their lexical version is the more common
one certainly I would be more likely to
use a lexical version than a than a
dynamic version but I know there are
others in this meeting who would
disagree with me or whose coding
patterns are different than mine okay
can I just make first of all the message
version of confirm the actual message
might be generated deep down in
something else so that's that's kind of
dynamic that's not very lexical that's
remember we should talk about that to
which we talk about the types of
confirmed another point how are you
implementing the lexical enclosing
confirm how's that implemented I mean
these are sort of you know prototype
implementations but the way I'm doing
the the dynamic one is being done the
throw and catch the lexical one is done
by basically it makes it makes them
module then it defines it generates a
UUID as a tag and then it it generates
it makes like a local thing called local
confirm local confirmed by etc makes
local versions of all the confirms it
replaces you know Lex it would replace
all the confirms with local confirms
then it replaces them back when it's
done it'll be kind of nice if the
lexical confirm didn't need an enclose
it just confirmed out to the enclosing
function right like return basically
return should be yeah I mean the only
thing like we actually talked about this
I think briefly last meeting but I think
it's just that the the semantics of
return are too weird well but we could
have this is a new function it could
have sure well-defined not weird well
sure I mean but there are also cases
where you want like lexical where I
think you want lexical you know with an
enclosed right so I've got some examples
here like maybe you could nest you mean
you have enclosed inside and closed you
mean
no no Tom you were suggesting something
which is can you have a naked confirm in
a function where when you type confirm
it is some kind of within that function
confirm that that resolves itself with
an implied in close at the exterior of
that function rather than propagating
like what I was asking yes right so it's
a function level confirm yeah that's
possibility maybe you should show some
more examples Christy yeah and then
kinds of confirmed yeah yeah so so I
mean you know here's some an I don't
know so the basic here's some basic
example so for example here right you
can run this you can use confirm match
which would give a pattern and it will
check if it matches that pattern and so
in this case it it ran it and in this
case if I do sine of sine of X where
well actually evaluate then it will in
this case it will throw failure then
there's also that and then and then
there's also the the second argument of
enclose which lets you do you know error
handling I think this is sort of a nice
real-world example so right if we get
from use entity value we get GPS and
populations one thing you might want to
do is you know if you get the GDP per
capita and maybe the quantity magnitude
of that this is kind of the natural code
you would write but you get this sort of
garbage in it and so as an alternative
you know here's sort of another way of
doing it where you map over these you
confirm that basically the two the two
pieces we're not missing or failed and
then you get the quantity magnitude and
then critically you wrap and close
around the you know the inside of that
pure function so it's just going to
enclose it at each you know step it's
not going to enclose the entire
evaluation and if that particular step
failed it will just return missing and
so if you run this you get a sort of
much cleaner output I think it's worth
walking through this piece of code
because this is an interesting example
right because what you need to do if you
don't have enclose and confirm it's
pretty messy sure a bunch of ifs there
um would it make sense to have a level
spec for confirm so you can specify you
don't want missing or failed anywhere in
the expression yes I mean we in the
earlier version of confirm
there was a level spec but it turns out
I mean here's the thing the first point
is that you can map confirm over an
expression and that works right now so
that's you can kind of get around the
lack of a level spec like that and then
the other thing is that it would just
became kind of argument clutter because
they do actually have a few arguments
and so if you had to specify the level
spec every time I think would get very
long the fact that the mapping of
confirmed works is interesting and there
has to do with the way that the rewrite
of confirm into this lexical head thing
works right what's happening when you
map confirm is it's turning the confirm
into this tagged version of confirm yeah
I mean it has to do something like that
I mean that's what's doing right now
enclose outside of the map you know
around the whole map right yeah that's a
good that's a good point so if I if I
put some clothes around the whole thing
and I'll also make it you know I could
have the same function then and then the
whole thing will be missing right
because because basically you know here
it's like it's again it's like cache so
so it goes out to you you know the in
close and closes the entire function the
whole thing and the evaluation stops
when the first confirm gets a failure
right yes yes like throw what made that
into a dynamic confirm well this is
lexical right because look the confirm
appears lexically inside a new clothes
well it sort of reached through no it
didn't reach anywhere I mean in the same
way that module is lexical right now
these are green even though it yes
you're right I mean it's not it has to
look inside the code in some sense but
yeah right i mean i you know i will not
discount this as you know sort of a
valid coding cell but at least to me
this particular example it would be more
natural to use delete missing first to
delete the entries worth missing and
then
whether you but you want to keep the
missing values as missing
for example correspond to other things
make the association right and you if
you put a hash inside the missing and
you say a second argument confirm you
could say missing no people missing no
money sort of thing right
sure yeah that's true should be nice to
oh there's no way can close and confirm
there's no sorry can you just evaluate
this without enclosing confirm sure yeah
yeah let me wait where's the version
here's the version that works I mean
make a new notebooks this isn't so
there's no enclose and then then then
you get stuff like this right so so by
the way I mean just to just to go over
that the example I forgot to reset it
but if you wanted to say missing no
people missing no whatever then you can
you can use the information section here
so I can say no no GDP and then here I
can say no people and then for the
enclosure you know handle I could say
hash of just say cash information that
without the quotes yeah anyway what's a
failure object so I don't know if that
works but yeah but see now it says
missing or GDP looks like it's mostly
missing no GDP but yeah probably because
the GDP fires first
yes probably they're probably all
missing together but oh yeah that's
there was a question on the live stream
so you always it to use switch and a
master in closed to handle multiple
types of confirms from various
underlying bits of code I don't think so
right because at the point is it all the
confirms they they immediately stop
everything so you can never really have
to confirms at once I mean you could
have some sort of there's a confirm
inside the handler function for the you
know for the enclose you can have stuff
like that but you know you can't have to
encloses sort of trigger
in the same piece of code at once let's
talk about the different kinds of
confirm so the original the main confirm
does what it looks for what inside it so
right now it just looks for failure Q
and missing Q but it could probably also
look for messages right and it
potentially has a you say messages you
mean that something triggered a message
somewhere in the evaluation not not a
result yeah I mean like an unquiet it I
mean the same stuff that like check kind
of catches right now okay so we're gonna
nitpick I'd say dollar cancel dollar
boarded should be in there too so okay
yeah that's dollar canceled is a good
one for sure
and then um truth on our live stream is
asking what the nested enclosed be
confusing so you don't know which
confirm belongs to which so I believe
that it does not get confusing but can
you comment on that yeah I mean so if
you're using tags then it's the same
semantics as throwing catch which I
believe is the inner one gets gets used
and if its lexical then it's also the
inner one gets used so yeah that's
that's it's the same as like throwing
catch but I mean arguably I mean I don't
know maybe it could turn red or
something but I don't know if that would
be necessary I mean that's like what
module does one suggestion this concept
of info in the second argument of
confirm why not having there the full
object you are returning so if you want
to return a failure object you put there
a failure object and if you want to
return to our fail you put the dollar
failed so I don't understand why this
info goes into a failure object and then
the handling function has to start by
extracting from a failure object good
okay yeah sorry basically you're saying
is that you could have it so that the
failure object gets processed at the
level of confirm or you could have it to
the failure object it's processed at the
level of being closed right the reason
to have a faith the reason to have
confirmed generically throw a failure
object is for nested in close handling
right what
that's true but I don't think that's
what that's what Jose is talking about I
would say I think was talking about if
I'm understanding you
that basically right there's the second
argument info and right now at the
confirm level all you can do is pack
stuff into this failure object that's
being inevitably thrown up to the
enclose and then if you want to turn
that failure object into something more
beautiful then you have to do that at
the enclosed level and the question is
why don't you do that at the confirm
exactly yeah just put whatever you want
and and it's it's a bit like first with
the default element if something goes
wrong just put here immediately what do
you want instead what so now okay so
here here's a question now so for
example I think more often okay so I
think pretty often you want to be able
to control from the enclosed what
happens on a failure more often than you
want to control it on a confirm right so
in this case in this example it was
definitely you know you kind of want to
control it the confirm level I think
more often if you have a big piece of
code and it's got lots of confirms in it
and the confirms you know they're
different confirms they're doing
different things and you don't really
want to annotate each one but you do
want it's that you know after the if a
confirm is triggered then the enclose
will be given a failure object and and
maybe who knows what this function
returns so it's got a process that
failure object in some way right and you
don't want to put that processing code
in every single confirm just is
confirmed as one come on missingno GDP
right right but then the thing is is
what about the case of so consider
consider this case though this is not a
much better case but you know in this
case where I I don't I just want to be
missing no matter how it was missing
right I don't want to annotate it so the
point is I could have a really big piece
of code that you know does all sorts of
complicated stuff and it can fail in all
sorts of different ways and also
different confirms can be triggered and
I don't really want you know and maybe I
have a single way that's processed at
the end right like if any failures
thrown for example return evaluated
that's an example that like some
function some internal functions use and
so you don't want to have
just try and specify you know kind of
return on evaluated inside of each
confirm you want to do that at the top
well I guess I wanna make two points one
is I mean these aren't necessarily
incompatible right if there's a you
could have a function of what to do with
the result in enclose and you know the
confirm could you know send whatever it
wants to be eaten by that function
that's what that's what exists right now
right
no no what exists right now is that it
throws a failure object that you can
apply a function to and you can add a
field to that failure object but I want
to push back a little bit on the idea
that this is similar to the first to the
second argument to first because that's
you providing how to proceed and this is
a matter of how to stop right here
you're providing information on what
went wrong and you're stopping as
opposed to saying no just do this and
continue anyway are you talking about
the second argument do you mean like the
right right so they made the analogy
between the second argument of confirm
and the second argument of first and I
am pushing back on that analogy because
when you give first a second argument
you're telling it well pretend that this
didn't happen and just pretend no errors
have been used to spell you and continue
on your merry way whereas here you're
actually stopping the processing and
you're sending information about 120
you know I don't think that they're
necessarily super analogous the
difference is that here we have
additionally a hundred function which
with the value identity would be the
situation I was right right I mean okay
so look I think we should pin that
particular issue of I agree that there's
a thing to discuss here of what of what
is how much of what is finally to be
returned is defined by the confirm
verses by the enclose
um it seems like a good issue to discuss
there's a the comment on our live stream
is don't fully understand from Ethan
here um saying he doesn't want to keep
rewriting confirm I'm not quite sure I
understand this but but I think one of
the implications of what he's saying is
maybe there should be in some kind of
enclose that it's that expects Auto
confirms as in for example you could
imagine and enclose maybe this is a bad
idea maybe this is trivial in fact yes
I'm sorry this is trivial this is it I
was going to suggest in close of
confirmed quiet in other words well we
should go I mean this is this is right I
mean unfortunately this is actually a
quotes somewhat useful construct because
basically this is the thing that checks
should be but there does enclose quiet
or something which which but let's go
let's go through the other types of
confirms because I think that will help
in under in explaining it might be used
and there probably also other confirms
that people will will know about that
should exist so okay so the confirms
that exists right now is there's the
basic confirm which you know this this
is like a heuristic one that's just
should just you know get most cases but
it will miss a bunch then they're the
sort of more you know specific ones just
confirmed by so this one you basically
give it a function and if it doesn't
return true Q if true Q of f of X /
isn't true then you know it will fail so
this would be something like you know if
I had enclosed of f of confirm by you
know region intersection of who knows
what you know confirm that this is a
region right that would be an example
right then there's confirm match which
is the exactly analogous thing but it
takes a pattern you know this is not
exactly the same but yeah and then
there's yeah confirmed quiet which
checks for messages and which should
have an argument a sort of a second
argument that's analogous to the
argument for check
where you can specify which messages you
want to kind of catch yeah and then and
then the final one is this confirm
assert which is the slightly different
in that it doesn't have this kind of
echo like property like it doesn't pass
through things it's just given a test
and it's just like assert except it will
throw a failure to the enclose so this
is actually you know exactly the same as
you know this is the same as this
basically except that it will probably
include slightly different things in the
failure object it throws the people
understand it so okay let's talk about
confirm quiet for a minute because I
think confirmed quiet is a little bit
more complicated than you're letting on
okay I mean confirm quiet is the only
one of these that reaches execution-wise
into everything that's inside it
everything else just looks at the
surface right confirm confirm confirm
match they all just look at what what is
being returned to them they inspect it
and they confirm that it has some
particular form confirm quiet does it in
fact does it throw immediately that the
message is generated does it wait until
it until the rest of the thing is is is
executed it throws immediately unlike
check I see and I should also mention so
here's an example it actually does not
throw the message it only throws the
message here because of a bug with text
string which is used by failure which is
why this is infinity and not one over
zero but yeah so so it it does actually
catch the message but yeah but it
doesn't in fact quiet the message that
you would do separately no no it does
quiet the message so I'm saying so if I
run it see if I'm running it right now
it quiets the message the only time the
message comes up is because in
displaying the failure odds oh I got a
good runs it yeah yep okay you can just
add a semicolon print of foo after the
confirm quiet just to prove that it
really is right yeah
yeah but they print inside the confirm
quiet aft
yeah put it there I mean it doesn't
right so this is the weird thing about
confirmed quiet at some level doesn't
matter right yeah I could put the
brackets here and it would be the same
but yeah
oh no it's who that I don't immediately
understand that okay well I should I
should look at this I would expect that
not to return not to print foo right and
because it's showing check like behavior
as opposed to yeah it should not show
check like behavior uh probably I mean
check it well I mean right there thing
about check that makes it kind of
frustrating is that right normally just
have a long piece of code and you just
say oh it's hopeless if it throws a
message and just stop so ya know that's
probably what this should do okay let's
talk about message buckets which is the
question is our all messages created
equal answer obviously no some messages
are more concerning than others the
question is can we meaningfully define
message buckets we have a partial effort
at defining message buckets from long
long ago
well what version was message groups
added in six seven um it's probably not
been well maintained but I don't think
that the message groups thing is the
right kind of bucketing for confirmed
quiet because I think what you want for
confirm quiet is I mean and okay the
several points here one is this whole
question about you know things returning
unev alyou ated oh that's we want to
know that things returned and evaluated
because they're not supposed to the
semantics of quotes return on evaluate
it seems completely messy and it seems
better to push people to use confirm
match and confirm by to define what they
mean by quote son evaluated okay so this
is it okay this is a discussion which
right there should be yeah all right I
was going to say I mean if the input is
thank you
to the output that is probably an error
that should be caught by just plain
confirm because of five right but why
would you write confirm around to
[Music]
assuming it's hold first but I mean but
nobody oh this is the problem with that
is that then it means that if I have
right so so for example let's say I have
a list of things right and I want to say
confirm /at right you know maybe I'm
timing you know F of confirm who knows
what but I'm running this you see you
see where this is going so right so so
the point is is that by the time this is
equivalent to this and by the time it
gets inserted here you know just to just
to demonstrate right right right exactly
mm-hmm well so this is a reason why so I
mean one of the things we talked about
last time but not for very long was the
idea of some sort of confirm evaluates
or confirm changes or something like
that which would basically be this but
it but for this reason and because of
things like two plus X and X plus two
give different results you know they're
sort of there's some weird properties of
such a function about combining these
disconfirm match also do confirm no
confirm match just does match so if you
wanted to do both things
oh you could I mean obviously you could
set up a pattern for confirmed match but
you understand what I'm saying if no you
just do that won't do them both right
all right yeah you have to do that well
yeah you have to have this confirms
Christopher when you have things that he
brought you a to themselves are you not
what are you worried what are you
worried about is it down values that
don't trigger sorry what do you mean for
you mean we should have is it down
values that don't trigger no he's
worried about the fact that he might be
mapping confirmed a bunch of curl a
bunch of a across a bunch of things some
of which evaluate non-trivial e
and others like to do not he's talking
about this is I mean the case we're
talking about right is is that there are
some functions like you know like that
example would integrate right where
where were this this decided to return
on evaluated and there are times when
you consider that a failure I mean like
like maybe not for this integrate case
but there are other examples where
functions you turn about unev al you
ated when they fail so what right so
plot of X comma X there you go perfect
yeah so I mean so I would actually argue
you know ok so that the hacky the kind
of hacky wait I think most people deal
with this right now is they check if the
head changes but I think that this is
actually the correct thing to do because
well this is this is pretty much the
correct thing to do but I think that the
head changing you know if the head
change if the head change that means
that it's actually you know evaluated in
a non-trivial way and if the head
doesn't change that means that it best
it evaluated in a trivial way by you
know maybe it turned into some other
case of itself that makes sense so in
this case what you would do here is you
would say confirm match of plot X comma
X comma underscore graphics or perhaps
no not not necessarily I accept plot
because plot doesn't necessarily return
a graphics return legend did yeah so so
this is right so I mean the question is
at some of all I think if there will be
a function that's kind of the check if
it was unavailable I would actually
argue it should check the head changed
in some sense right I mean this deals
with the case of 2 plus X versus X plus
2 and it deals with it deals with a
bunch of cases like that now it is
missing some cases like for example so I
mean one thing that's that's very
distinctly different so I agree with the
case that you gave that that's really a
true failure case they integrate you can
still do a bunch of things on it you can
differentiate it you can asymptotically
develop it you can do you know there's a
bunch of other things that you can do so
that that acts as an actual sort of
model that you don't want to have to
kind of type in again if that
a definite integrate you could
numerically integrate it and so on so
actually you mean just that that you
know there are some cases where things
return on evaluated but that's still
useful is that yes that's what I'm
saying yeah because they are effectively
models and we have actually you know
large and growing workflows that rely on
that you know that so we have a bunch of
functions that are active they try to do
something but they can also be inactive
you know either unev a lead or
explicitly inactive where they represent
something that you can informally
manipulate no regions is another good
example like those disks the disk itself
is a model of a disk you know and if you
have a parameter that it's like a whole
family of them and you want to be able
to actually deal with that whole family
of disks
right I mean exactly I mean that that's
why right so so I mean the thing is
though is that this is why me it's an
optional thing right there are some
cases where for example that region
intersection area and this is a
particularly hard case because the head
does actually change right there are
some cases right there's a bunch of
other in in probability and statistics
like so so these what's called direct so
these are derived regions and new
regions from old regions we also derived
distributions new distributions from old
distributions a transform distribution
often return unabated but yes it is it
still gas and stuff like you can get the
PDF you can generate random numbers you
can do everything like you could do with
a distribution right of course right I
mean so the point is this is the thing
about returning evaluators that
sometimes like in the case of plot of X
comma X we're telling an evaluator is a
failure mode excited what nothing
matched but they're also cases where
it's it's really not a failure mode or
where it's a it's a I mean in the case
of you know transform region or
something like that I I mean I would
have argue it's a weird
well transformation is a particularly
hard case but in many of these cited
argue it's actually kind of a weird like
pseudo failure it's like I don't have
enough information yet to turn into
something meaningful but if you give me
an R in this example of the region
intersection then I can actually turn
into a you know something else but but
no I mean we happily work with I mean by
design we intend to work with these sort
of parametric regions yeah that's not a
failure it's it's a it's an advantage
but you know what one could do I mean
but I think that if we can bucket but
I've seen many functions that come out
and now return unev a late and there is
nothing meaningful you can do and I kind
of would like to prune them out because
it's it pollutes the meaning of
unevaluated being useful yeah exactly
what
there's some edge cases though I mean so
so here's an example that I think I
think you even brought up last time
which is which is part right and now
that's indexed right where you like part
being able to to be unev alyou ated
except we've mad at the message right
but the index gets around this so I mean
that's an example though where even
though in some you know in most contexts
part returning unevaluated it's you know
a catastrophic failure it's like it's
something horribly wrong but there are
in principle times we might like to have
it unevaluated
yeah and if we can if we can more
clearly define define those cases and
sort of you know if some one level of
bucketing is saying that that this
should rather go to sort of failed like
if you do file operation they basically
return failed they don't sort of stay on
evaluate it if it can't do its thing
yeah roll why well I would say most file
operations if you give it something
that's structurally invalid that they
returns something they return unev al
you aidid but if you give it something
where it try you know where it's not
possible to do then it you know returns
you know a failed a dollar failed or
some equivalent failure type thing so
even on our live stream is is
complaining that the confirmed functions
a symptomatic of the root problem that
message is ancient and needs an overhaul
I don't think that's quite correct I
mean I don't disagree that message is
ancient it needs overhaul but I think
there's more to I mean there's plenty of
things like missing that is perfectly
valid symbolic thing to deal with that
is not a message type failure type thing
but nevertheless is convenient to be
able to handle programmatically and this
is this is part of the story of doing
that I think but I think the thing is
that it is true many ways messages are a
little bit you know in need of overhaul
but I think that the like there the
problem with messages is that is that
for humans right messages are
and they're hard to categorize because
that you know and and they're not
categorized for that reason and you know
some messages are catastrophic and
others are just like you know a little
you know just so you know it's context
dependent yeah no I told you I tried to
sort of basically split them into errors
and warnings and it just sort of gave up
after a while but it's well so the
question for us here is confirm quiet
does it have buckets of messages I think
it will be useful if it did that is
confirm quiet say there are no
structural error messages let's say like
part things and so on there could be a
such and such a function failed to
converge etcetera etcetera but there are
no you know right so I would say that
that confirmed quiet and actually check
and quiet in general so check and quiet
both take you know specific messages
lists of messages and message groups and
surely confirm quiet should take as well
well it'd be really nice is if you could
use patterns which are like you know log
plot colon colon blank and you know
blank colon colon you know what that's
the problem I think there's no reason
this shouldn't work right just just do
the you know check if the pattern
matches my message is thrown that should
absolutely work I think I I'm actually
just checked not do that the problem is
that message if you look at the
syntactic form of a colon colon message
it's a weird weird thing it's not what
you think because it's automatically
stringer fiying the second piece and so
on well it's it's message name of
something comma right right so that
doesn't right you need to do all is
saying that we need a new concept of
exception object
we have talked about this but let's
let's just I mean I think this is this
is what a failure object is like I mean
I think we can probably spruce up
failure objects of X I think they do
have some weird properties but I think
failure objects are you know if we had
an exception object it would be the
failure object and there wouldn't be
something I mean an exception object
sounds like it itself is hot to handle
and as soon as it's generated it starts
propagating places but I don't think we
want that particularly because failure
is just a symbolic thing that sits there
right failure is right I mean but this
is the yeah I know this is this this is
a syntax question of whether you call it
an exception on it or a failure object
I'm busy synonymous I mean all right so
maybe we should return so we have not
addressed this question about buckets of
messages I mean it's somewhat yes I just
think it's gonna be important to people
to be able to say I have this piece of
code it's you know important code and I
want to make sure if something really
horrible happened inside it I want to
exit if something that is a minor
quibble happens inside it but there's
one issue right now is we've got a big
agonizing about should a mess so here's
a question if a message is off does
confirm quiet still see it
no that's unfortunate
it should be I think it should be the
same as check it's actually with check
if a message is off
can you still check for it not unless
you unquiet of unquiet it inside of the
check that's horrifying basically I
think that's a mistake right yeah well
it's almost impossible to do any
evaluation without quote you know
quieted messages I mean do you know
fubar shift-enter you just generated a
message you don't know it but you just
created a new sim message which you know
is what makes debugging bugs in messages
so entirely painful because way more are
generated than you ever see okay so hold
on let's talk about that for a second
okay
because this idea of chatty messages
which are off by default and being able
to handle those programmatically seems
to me interesting
that is that because you know if we did
that we could have a bunch of advisory
things in code which could be picked up
by confirmed quiet but which will not
bother the poor human user so to speak
what's any better that is I don't that I
don't think that's practical I mean if
you if if if you gave confirmed quiet
specific things to look for fine but
you're saying all quieted messages
that's far too many to be well ok fair
enough but then then that's why I'm
talking about message buckets because
it's a you know to me and maybe I'm
wrong to me one of the issues here is
you have something that you think is a
production piece of code okay if
something goes wrong you want it to
respond in some way like the server
can't respond to that request or some
such other thing rather than just
disgorging some random piece of internal
you know state okay um but on the other
hand if all that happened was some minor
you know this numerical integral didn't
converge quickly enough you don't want
to abort the whole thing for the sake of
that and I'm just saying can we
characterize that in a fairly general
way what when is something I mean this
is Rogers errors versus warnings and I
understand that's difficult but what I'm
asking is is there you know okay do
people think that Zoo this is a relevant
or important problem or do they not I
think it's irrelevant problem I think
when you talk messages by areas like geo
messages messages you're talking about a
logging system I'm not saying we should
have that but that's kind of what your
interns well perhaps it is yes and in
which in which you log all messages
including the new SIM messages and so on
which are basically noise but no I I
think what would be more useful would be
you know what Jose was saying is you
know right so you could have the
internet messages and the and the geo
messages and which are not maybe
necessarily distinct and then so if
you're writing
you know something that talks to a
server you can enable the internet
messages and then you don't have to
worry about you know and integrate
issuing a or my favorite example solve
issuing the message that it used inverse
functions so the solution set may not be
complete I mean which is absolutely an
important thing to know if you are doing
some symbolic computation and you need
to know how general your solution is but
if you're connecting to server you don't
care well so in fact we probably have an
Wolfram language data we probably have
some tagging of those of that type of
area per by function I suspect and so
this is another thing that we're looking
into as well which is getting even more
chatty which is progress monitoring yeah
I'm not sure that that's northug '''l
axis I think I mean but discussion here
in order to slant into that direction
you know some of the learnings are
really like super chatty like you see
here on screen right now see all these
plot functions act pend messages they
are they give a warning when the
adaptive refinement didn't reach its
goal what happens when you have a time
constraint what happens to enclose when
there's a time constraint inside it I
think the time constrained war will win
in some sense let me see like oh no you
wanna sleep pause it yeah I mean so L
want the enclosed for time constraint
and close there bort there yeah I mean
just as a general well I mean this is
this is a we catch all our exception
mechanism that we have all these
different balkanization of you know
exceptions and I was thinking what we're
trying that's what we're trying to deal
with here right right I mean it's very
confusing
to know what you know why right so let's
fix it Tom
okay so let's go back to the confirm in
closing what I was pleased to hear that
it was using throwing cash in maybe well
there's what should this case do I mean
it should this case if you say in close
confirm time constraint what does it do
then does confirm look for aborted or
not I I think it shouldn't because it
should be the same as you know it should
be the same as throw you know throw can
go through throw can go through anything
including including include including
and close right III don't think in close
should stop everything I think there
should be an argument of throw that you
can give this documented and simple that
in close does see what do you mean why
if you give it a tag of enclosed I think
the I think we should consider enclose
and confirm as sugar on throw and catch
in a simple way that makes it easy to
understand what they do but you're
suggesting that you should be able to
throw to an enclosing in close yeah with
the appropriate you know arguments that
maybe throw the failure or something I
know you can't do that that'll break
well I suppose that'll won't break
anything because there won't be any
enclose but yeah yeah it's good work
there so would I mean so would I what
about the situation about lexical versus
dynamic so so right because I mean
basically the way in close works I mean
the way it implements its lexical stuff
is the debt it secretly always has a tag
right it just adds the tag lexically
when it's not provided so a to consider
that is some sort of and you you know
I'm not so bothered by that I'm thinking
about the global you know the thing that
goes up so so what about this case what
about the case of I've got you know some
through and I've got through of you know
this-this-this does that right and I've
gotten close of know if I have this case
so this is basically the case of the
this is the same as the problem that
production throw-and-catch without a tag
has which is that you can catch user
throws
so if normal and close you know without
a tag let's say the habes like catch and
it catches all the throwers that appear
dynamically inside it would write that
in terms of confirm won't work because
the president has a tag it's not lexical
give it a tag yeah sure sure
so this I now you have to do like this
right so what I'm saying is it would be
quite useful to replace either the
confirm or the enclose with a throw or a
catch in some simple way don't see why
Tom I mean other than it's very
confusing when then we have to have
catch wrapped around enclose wrapped
around we you know then it makes it very
hard to have simple uniform constructs
that catch every but but but the problem
is that the tagging mechanism is
different for throwing catch you can
unify them you could unify them we've
done the taint of their tag space using
lexical tagging for throwing catch as
well no no no no the point is just the
point is just if you have a tag if you
have an explicit tag you could make it
so that that explicit tag is in the same
kind of tag space as thrown catch yes
right now it isn't right I think I think
that idea and then enclose and confirm
are just sugar I mean sugar is messy you
know it's not derogatory to say that
they're just convenience ways to make
throw and catch
do you know be more convenience right I
guess there's some there's some details
there like so for example if I provide
handler funk
here presumably that's called regardless
of whether was thrown to confirm or
throw right yeah okay I mean but I don't
really see a I mean like look at some of
them I think this is this is this is a
pretty safe thing to do because you know
if you've given your confirms and your
throw is the same tag like it's pretty
hard to accidentally do that well the
only point here is throw becomes the
sort of the equivalent of confirm assert
of true or false not quite because
because I mean depending on so I mean I
guess if we went with like what Jose was
saying earlier a little bit but the
points confirm assert no matter what
happens no matter what you put in it
will always throw a failure object you
know and you can stuff the failure
object with whatever stuff it with but
you know but so throw could throw
actually anything which would then but
then the enclosed function would get run
on the thing that has been thrown right
you know the handler function will get
run yeah right so maybe we should talk
through the lexical thing so just to be
clear for everybody the idea is this
case here with confirm in the function
foo not lexically inside the enclose
would not work unless there was a tag
given people understand that right yes
only something where it's enclosed like
module you know if you say there's an
inner you know it's it's literally
lexically in enclosed in the enclose I
mean it seems like the right thing to me
it seems like a good way to do it
because it's a very common case and you
know if you do want to do the the long
distance confirm then you put in a tag
yeah yeah I think that I think that'd be
the right there's a question right how
did document that had counterfeit I mean
the only doing I mean by the way just in
terms of long term encloses I think that
the way that you actually want to do
that is you want to you want to do
something like this right so
I'll put my I'll put my untagged one
there and I put in clothes you know in
that function and then when I call this
function you know because I've looked at
the source and I see it has any clothes
around it I know that it's kind of a
function that might throw and so I'm
gonna I'm gonna propagate that error if
there was one I think this is I mean
this is even we talked about this last
time about with throw-and-catch whether
or not you should throw all the way to
the top through all the functions you're
calling or whether you should sort of
catch it at each step and I think that
that right now throwing catch it's too
painful to catch it in each step but
that you know sort of semantically that
is the more beautiful thing to do which
is what this is I mean my concern is
that if you you know you end up with a
lot of confirms in the code and and
there's a nice there's a you're working
within a framework it's useful to know
that I have the safety net and I can
punch out to it whenever I need to
you mean that the safety nets all the
way at the top the safety note is you
know to enclose a tagged and close all
the way at the top yeah I think it a lot
of your graphics code for example Brett
that's exactly what you would do you
would just so much what I would continue
to do um and but I think my impression
was that that was you know what
Christopher
doesn't like Western paradigm why didn't
that sway that's the reason why you
would have a tag right why it's possible
to right no I suspect the following is
true if you are designing a large code
base that where individual functions
deep inside the code base will never be
called on their own your punch out
mechanism is the right mechanism right
if on the other hand every function deep
inside the code could be called on its
own you need something more like this
where you know where the functions
propagate because each individual
function you know you you don't want in
your case if you had uncaught confirms
from deep in the code
that will be undesirable you know
another disk or one of your deep
functions directly you know you never
expect your deep functions to be called
directly you do not realize that
interface exactly so I think that's is
that a correct difference here that if
you if you expect every function to be
callable then it's more sensible to have
these more local confirms and encloses
okay it's another it's just a question
of whether you like side-effects right
if you're running if you have a big
piece of code and you have lots of
little functions that again are never
gonna be called outside of this big
piece of code then it's very natural to
have side-effects right and then there
other cases where you know the structure
of your code is different or your coding
style is different and then you know you
maybe don't like side-effects as much
can we get some piece of code that in 91
could you take out the enclose yeah take
the enclosed just have yeah right fine I
evaluate that and then can you evaluate
food to of Dola failed just on its own
on its own yeah so this this okay that
does this possible answer for that is it
would just return dollar fail no message
it would just return dollar fails or or
the failure object itself or the failure
yeah you're or the failure I am I think
I think
to do that you need that again you need
that third argument to throw but yes
that that's the that could be a behavior
when it would do that by putting the
food to or by butcher returning to the
repple it would know yeah it would
return that would be the result of food
- right - so you're arguing that down
values should get automatic and closes
on American closes if they only if and
only if they have untying confirms the
scope of that confirm is lexical it's
just within the function well it's not
within the function that's within the
down value it's within the definition
that's given here right but I'm just
saying that as somebody who regularly
writes functions with multiple down
values right each down value is sort of
separately it in its own confer enclose
assuming they have confirms it seems
like it's very easy read the function
see that it hasn't enclosed around it
and then you know like I should use
confirm when I call this function but if
it's kind of implicit if there's a
confirm anywhere on the body it's less
you have to you have to go through a bit
more work to look at the body of the
function to determine if you need to
confirm it or not women if you need to
yeah this is the case is the case is
like I have a function and it might at
some of my function might return an
error right it might return a failure
object because I've confirms inside of
it and maybe there's an implicit or
explicit and close around it right and
now I'm gonna call this function from
another function it's nice to know oh
yeah this is a throwing function this is
a function that might give me a failure
object right yeah it's kind of it takes
away that that information of I can just
read you know to scan the definition and
seed it well but to be fair if there is
a confirm with a tag deep in the
function
you still could have that risk all right
there's a confirm of the tag it's going
to blow out of that function and go you
know sure yeah but somebody was pointing
out earlier like you know I think the
general style that we'll see if we adopt
this is you know internal functions use
that tag and public functions don't so
you know this could kind of become you
know not really part of the
documentation but you know part of like
if you're learning a new piece of code
it's helpful whereas if you have a
really internal function to use as a tag
hopefully you're not calling that anyway
well that that discussion went away but
that discussion was when we were having
a purely dynamic and close and confirm
if we have a lexical one I don't see why
internal code with new tags if you're
just doing everything lexically I mean
the only case is the Bret's case yeah I
think this is really silly this thing
about having Otto enclose let's say I
guess then there's the question of what
about the right hand side of rules and
replacements or is it really magical
magically tight two down values I think
then people wouldn't in practice do it
because I think that's a but but let's
talk about the rule case does the rule
case make any sense in other words the
activation the replacement of something
by a confirm is that is that a
reasonable thing to do and then I mean
if you do : greater than confirm it's
just executing the confirm and if it I
think I think the point is right you
need to you know when you write an
explicit and close you're you're saying
this is where the error should it should
run up until this point and then should
stop propagating right I think if you
have like a rule or something like that
it's too vague like the function case
could work because it's pretty you know
if you least if you're looking at some
piece of code it's pretty obvious yeah
this this is the end of the function
right and they said and I suppose if you
just happen to write a I guess that's an
interesting question so assuming we had
this auto behavior would that be over it
over it and I an explicit confirmed
because suppose I had sorry an explicit
enclose because suppose I had an
enclosed and then I had a replace
somewhere inside of that enclosed with
confirm with that assuming we
implemented something for rules would
that be restricted to the rule or would
it jump up to the hold-down value I
think it's one of many good reasons to
not implement this for rules right yeah
cuz yet yeah cuz it if I wouldn't want
my rules to suddenly stop matching
because I used confirm inside one of
them so just a couple of things here so
so I mean it looks sounds to me like
nobody sees anything horribly wrong with
these mechanisms and there is I mean
there's concern about the word confirm
just being sprinkled throughout code but
I think it's a heck of a lot better to
do that than to have all kinds of weird
well to have two other possibilities one
no error handling or too grotesque
procedural code trying to do error
handling now the the question is could
there be or should there be an even
shorter form of confirms syntactically
is that useful or where are people going
to end up using confirm match and
confirm by almost as much as they use
confirm anybody doesn't opinion about
that I mean I think that I think that
people probably will use I think that
confirm will probably be by far the most
common like at least in the examples
that I've you know played with you know
the I haven't had to use confirm by and
confirm match nearly as much and I mean
I think that right I mean especially if
you're propagating lots of errors then
you can use can just normal confirm so
there's a question which is also
suggesting of adding confirms using
CODIS
is that feasible and what would we want
it to do you see an if statement where
the third part is the throw suggest
changing it no but I mean then yo well
that's a good start
yes well well so if you had if you had
this idea of you know right if enclosed
if if we imagine there's no implicit
enclose they're all explicit right then
like Connor was saying yeah you can have
something where if you just look at the
function and you see oh yeah the outside
of this functions and enclose then then
you you kind of know it's a throwing
function and then if you call it maybe
you can suggest putting a confirm around
it because you know that it might throw
well and also if it needs an explicit
than clothes then clearly in the case
you've written for flew to the flew to
definition there the code assistance
tools can tell you to put the explicit
enclosed there other words what's it
gonna do if you don't have the explicit
and clothes that thing is going to put a
tag into the confirm and the tag will
never be caught yeah I mean sister this
is this is this is why oh yeah this is
why there needs to be heard argument for
throw is this exact case right here but
yeah right okay so I mean I do think
this this Auto enclosed is actually a
fairly good idea for functions but okay
so I mean what what will be the
heuristic for deciding when a confirm is
worth putting into code although them in
the case where it's an F throw you need
for code assistance yeah I mean does
anybody know maybe Brenton knows from
existing categories in the linter is
there something obvious other type
functions where you should say you know
should this have a confirm you know you
could say every time there's a division
you could say should this have a confirm
for the / 0 case yeah I mean the thing
that I'm worried about is that we're I
haven't really looked at these kinds of
patterns before they're definitely
anyone that I preface in with you know
if anyone comes up with patterns of yeah
like you're saying if you know the throw
whatever the example was earlier I can
definitely add that to some assistance
tool obviously but existing patterns
yeah for error-checking yeah I mean they
would all be variants on things like you
know using if if something you know but
but I'm taking a different example right
so I mean you could see a piece of code
that says you know a over B right and
the question you might ask is what if B
is 0 right no I think if you provide a
suggestion that says you should wrap the
can you you should use a confirm because
maybe B is 0 I think that's a little
pedantic well that's a question could we
is there a heuristic that allows us to
determine go ahead well no no sorry I
mean it's just that well so everyone
here knows this but for the sake of just
clarity Wolfram language is very very
dynamic and it's very hard to say
anything about static you know static
analysis of Wolfram language is very
hard well I understand but but that's
what I'm asking about like a over B what
is some example so air would be is a
case we're talking warning messages
error messages etc etc is 1 over 0 a
warning or an error well what are you
saying a over B or 1 over 0 well even
just but by the time look if you've got
a over B in the code okay there are
there are certainly cases where one
could look at the code and say gosh this
is going to fail if you have one over
zero right but the the thing is it's
power of B to the minus one so what I
mean I'm
my pointers still be a warning on any to
a negative exponent you could have right
well you might have but I mean that's
what I'm asking is is is that you say
that's too pedantic no I I'm not saying
that it depends on what you're trying to
do I mean if you're trying to write a
piece of absolutely bulletproof code
that is a case that you might care about
so I mean is this something I forget if
this is a thing that the lender does but
are there like link ting levels like can
I set the linter - - - pedantic and get
these sorts of messages oh absolutely
yeah there's there so there are a few
different dimensions in the lender and
there could always be more dimensions
obviously I've projected them down to
only two there is severity and there is
confidence level there could be more
like intentional and you know other
stuff but there are severe there are
severity and there that means warnings
versus errors versus fatal which will be
a mess for the exactly the reasons Road
confidence level which is saying you
know how confident are you even that
this is even a problem of which we could
only reach a hundred percent you know
confidence level in some tech
syntactical wrong you know type errors
everything else strictly speaking is
less than a hundred percent confidence
level and yeah so I mean it's just a you
know it's a matter of dialing in how
pedantic you want you lose if you want
less conflict so just a good give
another indication of a confirmed case
if you're returning an entity property
right in principle you could find out
you know could it be missing right and
we could even know we can even have a
table of which entity property pairs
which entity type properties have
missings in them because there may be
some where there's just no missings
if you ask for the atomic number of a
chemical element there will never be a
missing if you ask for the others could
also change in principle but yeah yes
they could change they could change they
would have to be maintained I mean
that's an example work go ahead
you're 1 over X I agree it's a pretty
common case but if you if you draw that
to his conclusion what you're saying is
that for every singularity of a function
you should have a warning right because
the zero happens to be a singularity of
the power to the minus 1 right ok um
well we have lots of functions with lots
of singularities I know I know it's is
probably hopeless and zero times that
and you divide by 1 you need to look at
all the zeros of that function I mean
plenty of times I take get one over zero
somewhere and I get at complex infinity
and I say 1 over that and I get zero and
I'm very happy it was exactly the
correct behavior is also I mean right
and then there's also you know again
drawing to the conclusion there's also
stuff like every time you run part
should tell you oh you should make sure
that you have enough that the list is
long enough right it's like I mean in an
ideal world with a live check dependent
type checker yes but right I mean I
think folks on our live stream and not
understanding some of what's going on
here because because the fact is just
type 1 over 0 just for the sake of
understanding will actually have but ok
now type 1 over that well just type 1
over percent yeah I mean it's it's some
you know that's the life of a symbolic
system as you can get all kinds of
things here right um you were saying
about properties of entities yes example
as long as you know the string of the
property name that you're supplying all
of that's everything we're talking about
is lexical that could definitely be
maintained you know a table of known
properties and all of that that could
definitely be known statically and I
mean yes you know that that is another
it but so in your example of GDPs
that is a piece of code which I can
guarantee will fail some of the time
because there are missing you know
because there will be pieces that are
missing so if you saw that piece of code
without any confirms in it you know you
could reload assistance systems say you
probably want to put a confirm they're
ugly ways of doing
like for example some people might might
do this right that Oh
, right I mean there's an example of a
not particularly nice but works piece of
code it doesn't mean sightly different
but because something slightly different
yes but there's no there's no need to
put a confirm there well also being able
to put that confirm detect that lexical
a is very complicated because that's a
that's a thing where it was inserting
they've entity values things through the
you know through that function sure um
but okay I'm just doing out examples but
I'm just I'm just asking is there a
reasonable set of heuristics for
deciding when the code assistance tools
should suggest inserting and confirm the
first thing I'm gonna do with it is make
another function called confirm 200 that
for every HTTP request goes in and
checks that it's a 200 status yeah this
is that yeah I'm just gonna make it a
way to do that like if you use URL read
you can get the status code out of it
you have my coat is still call URL fetch
yeah so but with your all read exactly
yeah I'm gonna define this as a whole
holding attribute function and I'm gonna
use it all over like even today yeah
well most body right tune that case I
got the body and now what's something
that won't return 200 just typed of some
random how many O's can you put in do
though
huh this so I don't think we'll quite
work though oh wait I bet you can put a
lot of O's in that just put some others
okay now see this is a this is a case
where you'd have to do a layered this is
maybe something this is show it first
show it first show the first thing
shorter days so this will be a problem
still because this actually turns a
failure object in that case but if I do
this and it should work right
it returns I say it returns of there's
no of body as I go that's an HTTP
response with a different response code
if it was a good domain but a bad path
you probably get what you want show that
Cobra is interesting to see that it's a
confirmed by and a confirm that are
needed yeah in this particular case
actually you don't need to confirm
because in fact you know failure of
status code equals 200 returns false but
yeah but that's by coincidence yeah just
a coincidental thing yeah how common is
it that you need nested confirms like
that probably not very common it's for
things functions that return failure and
have another condition associated with
them yeah yeah I mean this is the nice
confirmation no this language is about
as far away from having static type
information as you could possibly
imagine everything is an expression the
um the compiler tries to derive static
type of information but that's a whole
different issue yeah that this is
everything is runtime here so by the way
is it
just talking briefly about the what are
you doing I have a question so Bob was
saying the first thing he was gonna do
is go off and create his own confirm
function right and so then that
basically means that that has to work in
a tagged form right there's no oh yeah
it'll be tagged when I'm sure what do
you mean is sort of no way to extend the
lexical version oh that's interesting so
in other words he couldn't put a confirm
200 and expected to be caught by an
enclosed without tagging the enclose
that's a very interesting point right
well okay so what imagine some system
where you've registered new confirm
functions and then the lexical tagger
picks them up yes that seems very
complicated well and also there's
complicated stuff because you need to
define so so here's here's a funky
little thing right so so confirm has
multiple usage lines but this is the
only one that actually needs to be
implemented with the with the symbol
called confirm because basically if the
symbol called confirm has ever run
without a tag right then then something
that's gone horribly wrong because there
should be an enclosed around it that
gave it a tag or should have a tag
already and so these other cases are all
implemented only for quotes local
confirm that the like module variable
right because it the other versions will
never ever ever get run so there's an
example of why this also becomes more
complicated I mean you certainly yeah
there isn't we don't have any mechanism
for user level scoping construct
construction but you can't make a user
level I don't think you can very
intimate ways or something yeah I don't
think you can do that um and I mean the
fact that there hasn't been a big
sort of issue one way of doing things
like that is with a macro system where
you know okay we should we should wrap
this up soon do you want to say
something Christopher about the about
the headdress version of this um yes I
need more local yeah I mean so this is
it this is a okay this is an example
like for here so one weird thing that
you can get is okay so so let's suppose
you know this piece of code could be
much longer right like I could use hash
part 1 and a bunch of cases and I could
use or maybe you know I'm using a ply
and so it's it's hash one and hash two
right I could use hash one in a bunch of
places and separately I use hash two in
a bunch of places so the question is do
I put confirm around every single time I
use hash one because that seems a little
bit painful so I mean one way of getting
around that you know would be if you had
some sort of you know headdress or
something which basically runs confirm
on the arguments write that out as it
would be with confirmed I don't think it
is
that's not writable either will be a
confirmed in the this this is that's not
right it will be a confirmed in the
device yeah right right so it would be
you have to have it divided you have to
call it divided you have to say
confirmed this particular example
doesn't work but so the point is those
is you know like let's say I'm mapping
you know if I'm mapping some function
that takes you know it takes it an
argument hash and I use hash at many
different times inside the secure
function do I confirm it every single
time I mention it
so I mean one one solution is to have a
headdress but part of the problem with a
headdress is that there are many
different types of confirm right now and
so you know are you going to also have
many different types of headdress
confirms I mean you could but it seems a
little bit yeah a little bit weird but
is it even useful I'm concerned that
this multi argument form is not
particularly that there are very few
cases I mean like take that divided case
it's a total cement
why don't I let me write out a concrete
example so suppose I have this and
suppose I want to get you know I want
hash part 1 or let's just get the GDP
right so we'll just get you know hash
squared over hash plus hash minus hash
right not a very profound function so am
I supposed to write confirm around every
single time hash appears okay and what's
the offended
what's this of the alternative I think
is the alternative would be something
like this so let me put this back you
could have something where it's it's
well okay let me let me write this a
little differently because again this is
a bit of a I don't think that's gonna
work
why wouldn't that be the same as just
using it on one of them if you're clever
to the first one that the evaluator sees
that's good you can absolutely do but
that requires you knowing which one the
evaluator will see first no that's not
terrible I mean that's not a terrible
thing but but even in that case
nothing's gonna happen
it's like echoing one of those hashes so
long as you do it for one of them the
actual function isn't gonna run until
they're all you know that that's a good
strategy right you just confirm one of
them well so okay but so now what about
any but there cases where for example
let's say I have F of this one and F is
a you know hold all some sort of holding
function right so it's gonna run all of
this no then it's gonna mess up right so
you need to you need to know a little
bit about how the evaluation is going to
work before you know which one the same
is true with that go I'm people do
manage to do that perfectly well so
what's the case I mean I'm just it
seeming to me like the case of the maybe
like construct for is is not convincing
that's mean if you I mean you could
always just do yeah
Open bracket confirm with hash semicolon
and then whatever you really wanted no
exactly right you could always just do
that yeah that's true that's an idiom
and it's not beautiful but that would
work
you know also you could have a second
function that just takes a single
argument of that you say is confirm you
know that right right right
you've messed nest the functions one
that you're talking about
maybe that's this other issue which is
about sort of single level error
propagation which i think is a totally
separate question okay but which which
has to deal the the case of I want to
map over some data and some of it is you
know missing let's say and and I just
want it to you know I just want it to
automatically propagate this missing up
and basically it's a function where it's
like you know yes that wrapper basically
you know and maybe it can be more
general than missing Q but um well how
would you do that with confirm and close
well you could do with the confirmed
enclosed that's the way you need it it's
one of these in naked
it's like saying clothes of this oh and
then and then well ok actually this is
how you would do it right now little
funky which is also speaking to Jose's
points about the hash information thing
yes yes way the term the word
information is probably not right right
yeah it's well I don't know what it is
it's a it's a it's a payload but that's
also really weird content something we
should play wrap this up they're just
persistent comments on our live stream
about about categorizing types of errors
which I mean we really think is
impossible so it's some um this point
about halting execution see we don't
have a notion of halting execution
nothing holds execution a warning
something the compiler would point out
of course of potential problem we don't
have a compiler yeah the only equivalent
to this is like an actual syntax error
which already get you know handled to
the speech right I mean I I just think
that this is okay I think we should get
this system in and start using it and
start for example so I would imagine
that there is a if we think about the
workflow of writing code some code will
be born confirmed so to speak with
confirms in it other code like for
example function repository code
I could imagine will be initially
written without this and then this will
be added as an outer you know added as a
as an add-on so to speak that what
people imagine or what what do you think
what do you think for people actually
writing code what will be the typical
pattern but I think the prototype code
will not have this as you try and make
the code sort of bulletproof for
production which is the time when right
now you're adding all kinds of weird
procedural throws and catches and so on
that's when you would put the stuff in
what do people think about that and
that's why I keep on talking about code
assistants as a way to help people to
quotes put it in I mean is that the
right workflow or should we expect
something different I mean I mean I have
thought the point is to and certainly
what I would value out of this is that
it's so trivial that I can write it
correctly the first time around I think
that's basically right I mean except
that I think it will be my bed now
you're talking about writing it the
wrong way and then later no I'm talking
it and throw over them to confirm let me
let me give the example I have no idea I
mean if you let me share for a second I
was I had some function up here um in
Thai some of us aren't capable of
perfection the first time like you mmm
yeah I mean so this is some random
function and this has been rewritten
since I wrote it but I wrote it a few
days ago and it's been rewritten since
then like I bet there are cases that if
I thought about it I realized that there
are edge conditions here where it could
fail right that that first last first
slash at position I guess a little bit
still be okay but for if it was first
step position it would you know
potentially yes you could potentially be
wrong right and that's a great example
where I would think you know Brenton's
tools could could tag that as a thing
where you might want to confirm it or
another one is the evolution part all
come or what the first line basically
you know evolution could be you know it
this does not check right so this is a
great example
this doesn't have checking code here I
probably should have you know but at the
very least the the next level of
bulletproofing would say well what
should this say this is confirmed quiet
basically on this or another thing I
think slightly cleaner but a little more
verbose of if you did like confirm
assert at the beginning just insert that
your inputs are sensible no there in the
graph where there's the join you would
want to check that the things have the
same head or that the result is not at
join you know that's a common thing well
but that's bulletproofing beyond I mean
this should be correct because I just
derived it inside here well I guess then
you should you should bulletproof
you should bulletproof inside of head
dependencies and tape dependencies
before you you know instead of bull
pooping around join is that what you're
saying sorry what are you saying you
wouldn't bulletproof around the join
because you would already a bulletproof
inside yeah that's what I'm suggesting
but I mean the question is how much
bulletproofing should one have like like
this particular thing and this is
something that could be known to the
code assistance tools that can't fail if
hash is a list you can always do that
this is just I mean are you talking
about in relation to what people should
do are you talking about in relation to
what code assistance should tell people
to do how do we know hash is a list well
position updates is a list because it's
the return value of position what I mean
this is very deep analysis that we're
talking about though I mean it's trivial
for humans to be you know reasoning
about this but like this this is very
could this be special case yes obvious
but you know we're talking about very
deep analysis tan that so in the near
term code in our code assistance will
not be able to do this I'm asking what
is the workflow that we expect for
people right like I wrote this function
fairly quickly it somehow got rewritten
by somebody because I wouldn't have used
those particular variable names and you
know and the question is when it goes in
the function repository by the way
somebody has a bunch of background noise
they might not know they had um the you
know when it got put in the function
repository it would be desirable to um
you know to somehow do some
bulletproofing on this and the question
is is that an add-on thing that um you
know one what will one expect this will
look like after it's been bullet-proofed
well have confirmed sprayed all over it
will it have a couple of confirms what
will happen I think that the thing is
this is not a great example because it's
some level this is a function that can
always run as long as you know evolution
is something sensible it'll always work
right all you really need to do is
assert that evolution is sensible I
think a better case would be something
it's like doing networking or it's or
it's you know calling you know calling
functions that sort of heuristic aliy
try and work but don't always work and
stuff like this right those are the
functions where where you really those
resource functions their potentially
hitting the network yep in the vertex I
on the edge style no it's true and I can
tell you something that will be very
useful for code analysis and determining
all of these kinds of things if all of
these functions have tests that can be
run then harkening back to the first
half of this session you know we could
run these functions instrumented in some
way you know these tests and we could
actually just notice have tools that
notice whatever these invariants are you
know hash is a list you know and all
these kinds of things you know in lieu
of having an actual type system you have
to figure stuff out at runtime but we
have a runtime system we can run about
you know if we have a you know if we
have tests that cover a lot
of our basis of how you expect something
to run we could notice what all of these
things look like when you're running
tests and then give suggestions based on
that data that you know from code that
has run I said it's hard to talk about
code and Wolfram language that hasn't
run but we can also just run code though
you know if we have tests and things so
it's not it's not so bad sometimes and
the heuristic you know invariants aren't
going to be perfect we will miss some
we'll have false positives and false
negatives but you know I think it would
be perfectly reasonable to come up with
some kind of 80% solution of keeping
track of and whatever the invariants are
that can be easily noticed when you're
running tests of all the functions so I
mean this would be an example of a
slightly more realistic complicated
thing Wow
why is there red color there wow that's
wild it's not a thing once he's very
often something that's actually red wow
that's really weird I think it's a it's
a dynamic module module question but why
is it I mean I don't even see what went
into scope or out oh I was passed in the
module I don't understand that at all
but in any case this part of a dynamic
but the variables in a module I think
that's the problem
yeah Wow should be in the dynamic module
that's always that's been read since
like version 5 or something but is this
is this in fact an error it's an error
that they should have put it in the
dynamic module yes God why didn't they
notice that well in the case um
um somebody it's commenting our lives to
as a programmer I don't want to do error
handling yeah well that's what we're
trying to do is we're trying to automate
it as much as possible um but in the end
yeah this is a bad example it's too long
I was I was thinking this might have
some other types of things in it I mean
this is this is a realistic I mean
that's a very formatted piece of code
but I mean this is somewhat realistic I
mean that you give me put in clothes
around the you know create document
there and and you know who knows I mean
look there's even that did to replace
that replaced there is a classic you
know classic idiom that you would want
to replace with a you know yes yeah I
don't know what the heck this is I mean
this is so I should that case it's not
in that case it's basically it's trying
to use resource function but if the
resource functions fail it's just gonna
use the symbol that's already there
right they mean that's local error
handling that's not a confirm thing I
don't really even recognize what this is
doing but um I think a question that
looks grotesque but common idiom I think
it's different from what's happening
here but there is an idiom which is I
call some function and then I use
replace basically like if and I say you
know if it was something silly then
replaced that with message and throw or
with whatever value I want to be to
default well sure I mean this is I think
good and the first one is a little bit
funky like that's the first one is I'd
what I think you want to replace with
confirm but the second one is legitimate
I think okay or or confirm what does it
confirm match I guess right this
oftentimes they write it that way
because it's simpler or perhaps more
more readable than if of match cue of
blah blah blah yeah you use confirmed
match too
yeah all right we should um Wow is that
okay
there's a comment about inherited block
what is inherited block it's block where
its internal inherited block and it's
block where things retain all their
definitions if it's in the function
repository which of course has some
overhead segments I'm going to use it
but the documentation is good um what
what does it do it doesn't it what it
does so Stephen instead of instead of
create value okay which which creates a
new value with cleared stuff it does it
does a create value where it keeps the
old values it's used for for things like
nd solve to implement evaluation monitor
and step monitor and what we mean look
at this example look at a second example
there and compared to let block would do
alright I see so it it can overwrite the
value but it room it saves the no I'm it
doesn't start with it with the value
cleared it starts with the value having
its current which you know right so
rather than trying right cuz you can't
really I mean you could do it for own
values but if you want to save you know
all the values you can't really do that
with block right fair enough okay um
well it's at least in the function
repository comment from Mohammed on the
live stream um fair enough
okay well look at this this to me this
looks I mean there were a few comments
here and a few things were thinking
about but otherwise I think it's where
we should be good to go to try and get
this into the twelve to prototype builds
that sound reasonable getting close
confirm stuff I think so I mean I think
it's one of those things where we're
going to have to get our hands dirty
using it and then we'll write that's
what I
think to I think the earlier it is in
builds the better and I mean I'm not
sure what's going to happen in terms of
code that starts to use it I mean maybe
it should try to get into the head
branch quickly enough that people can
actually start writing code with it
because that's the only way we're going
to know if it's right there's
substantial pieces of code working with
it anybody want to comment on that
Christopher did you get all the what you
need to get the build environment
working and so on yeah I mean you know
the only again the only details the
three argument throw which you know
which just breaks it in one particular
case well so there has to be redone can
you can you do that or does that require
somebody else to do that I mean I'm kind
of set up now to do it but yeah I mean I
don't know I mean I can I can I'm not
super you know my my knowledge of kernel
code comes from reading it but you know
I looked at this I don't think it's a
very I don't think it's a super
complicated change so you're an expert
then now Christopher yes I will reassign
all throw catch and other exception bugs
to you now excellent thanks for
volunteering I mean the only really
detail about that change that's that's
is that I think you have to make throw a
whole doll because right now it doesn't
assuming that the third argument is like
time constrained and it's something that
would be evaluated run as opposed to
being a function you know yeah well but
what would it do it would evaluate
immediately as if the other arguments it
would evaluate immediately as if it was
not hold all yeah anybody see an issue
with that
okay well let's wrap it up okay thanks
everybody and thanks to people on the
livestream for comments and and people
who were I have the impression there
were some people who are not very
familiar with often language this was a
very bizarre way to see the very bizarre
interaction because this is looking at a
very piece of metal programming so to
speak
that yeah check out some other
introductions
okay thanks all see y'all soon